si alguna vez te has preguntado para qué
sirve el mínimo común múltiplo y el
máximo común divisor tal vez este vídeo
te ayude a entenderlo mejor aquí tengo
dos problemas y vamos a ver si este
conocimiento nos ayuda a resolver ambos
problemas el primero habla sobre carlos
y danielle y dice lo siguiente carlos y
daniel están en clases distintas de
física en la universidad de santa rita
perfecto
el profesor de carlos siempre da
exámenes con 30 preguntas esto creo que
va a ser muy importante siempre de
exámenes con 30 preguntas el profesor de
física de carlos mientras que el
profesor de física de danielle siempre
da exámenes con 24 preguntas es más no
voy a poner con otro color el profesor
de daniel siempre da exámenes con 24
preguntas perfecto si antes de empezar
el curso ambos profesores acordaron
realizar la misma cantidad de preguntas
en el transcurso del año cuál es
el mínimo número de preguntas que
podrían aplicarles en el transcurso del
año y cuál es el mínimo número de
exámenes que tendría que aplicar cada
profesor ok vamos a ver qué es lo que
pasa con este problema cada vez que el
profesor de carlos después de un examen
al salón de carlos el examen consta de
30 preguntas por lo tanto si no tiene
exámenes en todo el año entonces tienen
cero preguntas pero si después aplica un
examen entonces van a tener 30 preguntas
y si después aplica otro examen pues 30
más 30 van a tener 60 preguntas en total
y después aplicar otro examen tendrían
90 preguntas 90 preguntas en el
transcurso del año y se aplica otro
examen tendría 90 más 30 que es 120 120
preguntas en el transcurso del año y si
después aplica otro examen serían 150
preguntas y así me puedo mantener y
mantener y mantener sumando 30 preguntas
por cada examen que se le ocurra será el
profesor de carlos pero vamos a ver si
ya con esto es más que necesario porque
quiero saber también qué es lo que pasa
con danielle entonces
déjame poner que este es el profesor de
carlos para no olvidarnos que carlos ok
para no olvidarnos de qué es lo que pasa
o qué es lo que sufre carlos en cada uno
de los exámenes y si ahora pensamos en
daniel el profesor de l'àngel cada vez
que aplica un examen su examen es de 24
preguntas por lo tanto si no aplica
ningún examen tendrían cero preguntas en
el año pero si después aplican a un
examen tendría 24 preguntas con espera
este 4 está muy feo o este 4 me parece
mejor y se aplica otro examen pues 24
más 24 preguntas serían 48 y si después
aplicar otro examen ese mismo profesor
pues 48 más 24 a 72 y se aplica otro
examen ese mismo profesor pues 72 + 24
me da 6 96 y se aplicará otro examen es
el mismo profesor pues serían otras 24
preguntas más porque siempre los
exámenes del profesor de danielle tienen
24 preguntas 96 más 24 es lo mismo que
es 120 y se aplicará otro examen más
este profe
tendrían 144 preguntas y así no puedo
seguir y seguir y seguir poniendo
exámenes por aquí entonces esto es lo
que le pasa a daniel y daniel está con
este color ok
danielle da y el ahora lo que me dice el
problema es que antes de empezar el
curso ambos profesores acordaron que
iban a realizar la misma cantidad de
preguntas en todo el transcurso del año
por lo tanto sin importar cuántos
exámenes realice cada uno de los
profesores al final del año tuvieron que
hacer las mismas preguntas en eso
quedaron ambos profesores si el profesor
de carlos hace exámenes siempre con 30
preguntas y el rangers siempre hace
exámenes con 24 preguntas cuál es el
mínimo número de preguntas que podrían
aplicarles en el transcurso del año es
la primera pregunta que me hace este
problema vamos a intentar resolver esta
primera pregunta cuál es el mínimo
número de preguntas que podrían
aplicarles en el transcurso del año y si
te das cuenta por más que queramos
siempre profesores de carlos va a
aplicar
exámenes de 30 y 30 y el de daniel de 24
24 así que si nos fijamos en un número
de preguntas que compartan estos dos
profesores pues 30 no sería 24 tampoco
60 no 48 no 90 tampoco 72 96 tampoco
pero ciento veinte 120 puede ser una
cantidad de preguntas que apliquen ambos
profesores en los cuales después de
aplicar un cierto número de exámenes
puedan coincidir si ambos profesores
aplican la misma cantidad de preguntas
en el transcurso del año podrían aplicar
120 preguntas porque es un número que es
divisible porque es un número que es un
múltiplo tanto de 30 como de 24
estoy buscando un múltiplo creo que esto
me da la idea de decir cuál es el mínimo
común múltiplo entre 30 y 24 lo que voy
a buscar es el mínimo común múltiplo de
estos dos para ver cuál es el mínimo
número de preguntas que pueden aplicar
estos dos profesores y si será 120 pues
vamos a corroborarlo para esto voy a
recordar la factorización en primos del
30 el 30 lo puedo ver tiene mitad la
mitad de 30 es 15 y al 15 también lo
podemos factorizar primos el 15 tiene
tercera que es 5 y si te das cuenta 2 3
y 5 ya sus números primos por lo tanto
estoy diciendo que al 30 al 30 lo puedo
escribir como dos por tres por cinco ok
y qué pasa con las 24 pues vamos a ver
el 24 por su parte también tiene mitad
hace que pongamos aquí un 2 y la mitad
de 24 es 12 12 por su parte
tiene mitad la mitad de 12 es 66 también
tiene mitad la mitad de 6 estrés tiene
este momento ya estoy encontrando todos
los factores primos de 24 2 2 2 y 3 es
decir que el 24 el 24 lo podemos
escribir como 2 por 2 x 2 por 3 ok ahora
si yo quiero el mínimo común múltiplo
entre 30 y 24 lo primero que voy a hacer
es escribir el 30 en su descomposición
de números primos que es justo esto que
tengo aquí por lo tanto vamos a
escribirlo a dos por tres por cinco ok
si nos fijamos en estos números formamos
al 30 pero también queremos formar el 24
por lo tanto el 24 se forman
multiplicando a dos por dos por dos por
tres pero aquí ya tengo un 27 en un 3 lo
único que me hace falta y es multiplicar
este 2 y este 2 también por lo tanto los
voy a poner aquí
por dos por dos por tres si yo junto a
estos de aquí voy a formar el 24 y ahora
si el mínimo común múltiplo entre 30 y
24 es 2 por 2 por dos por tres lo cual
es 24 por 5 cuantos 24 por 5 24 por 5 5
por 4 20 llevamos 25 por 2 10 y 2 son 12
120 justo el número que habíamos
encontrado hace rato 120 es la respuesta
de este problema cuando nos preguntamos
cuál es el mínimo número de preguntas
que podrían aplicarles en el transcurso
del año y seguramente por acá habrá
otros factores del 30 y del 24 pero el
mínimo es 120 ahora después nos
preguntan cuál es el mínimo número de
exámenes que tendrá que aplicar cada uno
de los profesores
el profesor de carlos en este caso va a
tener que hacer un examen dos exámenes
tres exámenes y cuatro exámenes
uno dos tres cuatro exámenes por lo
tanto el profesor de carlos profesor de
carlos va a aplicar cuatro exámenes va a
aplicar cuatro extras
ok y si nos fijamos en la miel bueno
pues el profesor de daniel va a aplicar
un examen dos exámenes 345 exámenes por
lo tanto el profesor el profesor de
daniel de miel
va a aplicar cinco exámenes cinco
exámenes y esa es la solución exámenes
de este problema de este primer problema
porque te tengo otro problema por acá
abajo así que vamos a generar todo este
problema y vamos a ver qué me dice el
siguiente problema habla sobre elena
dice elena dejan quitar esta herramienta
de aquí elena compró un paquete de 21
carpetas y un paquete de 30 lápices 21
carpetas y 30 lápices si ella quiere
usar todos los lápices de las carpetas
para crear juegos idénticos esto es muy
importante quiere crear juegos idénticos
del material de oficina para su
compañera de clase
cuál es el máximo número de conjuntos
idénticos juegos lo mismo idénticos es
una palabra clave que puede hacer usando
este material perfecto qué te parece si
ponemos las carpetas me gusta el color
rojo para las carpetas entonces vamos
las 21 carpetas aquí tengo una 2
4 5 6 7 y bueno si pongo todas las demás
va a ser bastante tardado así que
déjenme ver si puedo copiar y pegar esto
y déjame copiar esto control cm y lo voy
a pegar por acá ok ya tengo nuevas
carpetas aunque las voy a poner justo
por aquí y vamos a hacer lo mismo
control de ok ya tengo otras nuevas
carpetas y las voy a poner por acá estas
son las carpetas que tiene esta elena
las carpetas que compro elena ahora por
otra parte va a comprar lápices así que
voy a ponerlos con un acuerdo order de
30 lápices un lápiz 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10
ok tengo diez lápices aquí así que voy a
hacer lo mismo y como tengo 30 pues voy
a hacer esto tres veces lo voy a copiar
le voy a pegar primero ok me da este de
aquí los voy a poner justo acá abajo y
después tengo otro por acá control
cuando no aparece de hasta aquí aquí
tengo mis otros diez lápices perfecto y
lo que yo busco es el máximo número de
conjuntos idénticos que se puede hacer
usando este material y bueno todos estos
para que porque lo que estoy buscando y
fíjate lo que dice lo que estoy buscando
es crear juegos idénticos de material
para oficina y lo que me preguntan es
cuál es el máximo número de conjuntos
idénticos que puedo hacer usando este
material realmente lo que queremos es
dividir este número y este número entre
el número máximo de conjuntos idénticos
que pueda realizar y para esto qué te
parece si pensamos en el máximo común
divisor en el máximo común divisor o el
máximo como un factor si lo que llamar
así de 21 y de 30 de 21 y de 30 y como
lo encontraba bueno pues vamos a
factorizar en primos al 21 y al 30 al 21
primero y si los factores un primos que
me dan bueno pues el 21 tiene
y la tercera de 21-7 esto está muy
sencillo ok y si yo me tomo ahora al
otro número al 30 si yo quiero tomarme
el 30 descomponerlo en primos pues tiene
mitad la mitad de 30 es 15 y después 15
tiene tercera y la tercera de 15 es 5
justo esto es lo mismo que hicimos ese
rato recuerdas y para encontrar el
máximo común divisor entre estos dos lo
que me voy a fijar es los primos
compartidos aquí tengo un 3 y aquí tengo
un 3
aquí tengo un 7 aquí está el mundo sic y
tengo un 5 ya no se comparten más
números primos por lo tanto puedo decir
que el máximo común divisor entre 21 y
33 o dicho de otra manera el número más
grande que divide a ambos conjuntos es 3
y esto está de lujo porque si nos
fijamos en todos los factores de 21 que
no lo voy a hacer para no hacer este
vídeo mucho más largo pero todos puedes
buscar se encuentra todos los divisores
o todos los factores de 32 escribimos
aquí nos vamos a dar cuenta que el
máximo común divisor entre ellos es
decir el divisor en común que tengan y
que sea el número más grande va a ser 3
o dicho de otra manera lo que va a poder
hacer elena es crear tres conjuntos
primero tres conjuntos de siete con las
carpetas y después tres conjuntos de 10
con los lápices así en total cada vez
que encuentra a su compañera de clase le
va a dar un conjunto con siete carpetas
y diez lápices otro conjunto con siete
carpetas y diez lápices y por último
otro conjunto con siete carpetas y tres
lápices
aquí tengo a mis tres conjuntos que por
cierto es el máximo número de conjuntos
idénticos que puedo hacer usando 21
carpetas y 30 lápices